et pour parler de la situation en syrie
nous recevons sur ce plateau
morad el hattab écrivain et conseiller
en intelligence économique et en
investissement stratégique me suis à la
table bienvenu merci d'être avec nous
alors tout d'abord un pour commencer on
va essayer de contextualiser une
situation très délicate et très tendu
pourquoi la turquie est active
aujourd'hui dans le conflit syrien a
c'est la turquie tu actives comme elle
l'est en libye je pense que l les
principalement pour des raisons liées
aux matières premières c'est à dire au
gaz
je pense qu'actuellement on a à faire un
chantage de la part d'air dogan c'est
clair puisque ils essaient de bloquer la
construction des semaines et de garder
la main sur les deux robinets qui vont
alimenter en gaz demain et c'est pour ça
que de manière assez surprenante
il revient sur les accords de sotchi il
revient sur les pourparlers d'astana il
y est en train de trahir littéralement
c'est c c'est pour dire ce qu'ils ont
toujours soutenu c'est à dire la russie
et l'iran d'ailleurs ils sont allé
jusqu'à soutenir lorsqu'il a été victime
d'un coup d'état en 2016 et c'est vrai
que maire de gan aujourd'hui rêve d'une
chose c'est d'une zone exclusive
économique et de revenir sur les traité
de lausanne ouchy qu'ont été signés en
1925 pour
avoir ma mise sur la manne gazière en
méditerranée alors elle la tour qui l'a
dit elle n'a pas envie d'entrer en
confrontation avec la russie et
parallèlement elle est en train
d'affronter la série qui est soutenu par
moscou est ce que vous comprenez un peu
ce paradoxe de la turquie oui mais
justement c'est même au delà du paradoxe
je parle littéralement de trahison
aujourd'hui la turquie à rentrer en
guerre contre un état souverain légitime
dans six mois donc ils n'ont rien à y
faire en séries
d'autant plus qu'un accord avait été
trouvé avec le président assad où il
s'était assuré qu n'est pas de
formations kurdes aux frontières turques
ce qui est le cas mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé montre le processus d'astana
et maintenant pourquoi la turquie semble
comme ça changer de position alors ils
changent de position un peu partout il
change aussi en libye comme il change en
syrie il faut et je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité pour permettre d'élucider
cette pertinence il faut à percer
impérativement voir l'arrière-plan tout
ça la logique d'erdogan c'est une
logique de sultan ottoman il veut
impérativement retrouver cette grande
aire qu'avait la turquie entre 415 et
1912 on va dire qu'un 151 1912 et les
américains l'amérique d'obama lui avait
permis sa et croire et nous faire croire
que
la turquie agi pour le bien de la
population civile en syrie c'est
absolument faux tout on sait
qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui idleb c'est une poche de
terroristes fanatisés le terrorisme
attisé dont la turquie se sert aussi
pour alimenter le conflit libyen et
qu'on ait les mêmes qu'on retrouve dans
le sahel que nos forces françaises cro
bat donc perdre hogan
aujourd'hui il cherche tout bonnement à
légitimer sa présence en syrie comme il
l'a fait récemment avec la carte signée
et sa rage en libye pour avoir une
mainmise sur le contrôle du gaz alors on
à la syrie aujourd'hui qui se dit
déterminé à repousser l'offensive turque
qu'est ce qu'on doit prendre alors ce
qu'on doit craindre à mon sens je dis ça
avec beaucoup de recul est ce que c'est
vraiment une crainte je pense car dogan
s'il continue biking sur la touche ce qu
il en train de commettre
c'est peut-être même aller savoir qui
lui a permis est autorisé il faut
forcément des puissances des relevés est
ce que washington lui a autorisé à
permettre cette nouvelle offensive
je le crains pour lui et j'inviterai re
dogan à méditer cette phrase du roi
louis aux camps orgueil chevauchent
devant honte et désolation suivent de
près ce que je pense c'est que honte et
désolation arriveront cireres dokhan ça
veut dire que si actuellement il a des
alliés c'est une supputation soit lâchée
au je pense que ses alliés lui ont tendu
un très joli piège et que cette fois il
faudra qu'ils méditent à deux fois s'ils
veulent être de la russie et de l'iran
car il est en train de se mettre tout le
monde à dos même l'egypte il faut savoir
qu erdogan n'a jamais supporté l'accord
signé entre israël et l'egypte par
rapport au gaz en 2018 donc l'egypte
aussi israël chypre la grèce l'iran
l'irak
ça commence à faire beaucoup de monde
alors il ya qu un pays qui a pu lui dire
vous vous y allez je pense que ces mêmes
pays qui a dit à saddam hussein qui
pourraient aller
attaquer le fou rire alors très
rapidement vraiment n'a plus beaucoup de
temps on à l'article de france 24 qui
dirait qu apparemment il y aurait des
terroristes français présents à guimps à
ce que vous avez les informations sur ça
y est ce que ça pourrait être crédible
bien sûr les pigeons mais c'est crédible
d'autant que ces fameux terroristes
français djihadistes l'ont été avec le
blanc seing de l'ancien gouvernement
français je pense à françois hollande et
à laurent fabius qui rappelez-vous ce
qui a fait perdre toute notre
crédibilité
laurent fabius qui disait qu'elle ne
sera fait du bon boulot donc
effectivement je dois reconnaître
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron n'est pas
dans cette logique il a il a il a fait
savoir aux autorités turques
parce que nous on renseignements et nos
rafales ont pu intercepter des
livraisons d'armes passant par les bis
de la venue de mercenaires
si rien de glèbe en libye et dans le
sahel
donc je pense qu'effectivement oui je
vous le confirme je me confirme il y a
bel et bien des français djihadistes
présent à idleb qu'est la dernière poche
terroriste en série et je j'approuve la
légitimité du peuple du gouvernement
syrien a dégagé les terroristes hors de
chez eux
morad el hattab merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain et conseiller en intelligence
économique en investissements
stratégiques merci c'est moi qui vous
remercie